exotic fish and coral exotic fish and
coral at age 13 that's how Graham was
making money by taking pictures of
exotic fish and coral and getting paid
$1 for each picture that he uploaded to
the exotic fish and coral distribution
company's website and a little over 10
years later he reached a net worth of
over 1 million dollars by age 26 by the
age of 26 I was worth over a million
dollars but it definitely wasn't from
continuing his fish and coral
photography business see contrary to
popular belief most people in the middle
class and even in the lower class will
have earned more than 1 million dollars
in their lifetime before they die but
getting to a million dollars in net
worth by age 26 when most people have
barely gotten out of school that is
pretty impressive and it doesn't happen
by accident and just three years later
at 29 years old he's at a net worth of
over 6 million dollars and the story of
how he got there it's a story of drama
of betrayal of backstabbing of scamming
his way to millions it's it was actually
as honest of money as you can make and
pretty realistic for anyone else to
accomplish including you so enough of
the theatrics this is how Graham Stefan
became the six million dollar millennial
with all the juicy specifics that you
could ever ask for
[Music]
throughout history there has been one
industry that has always stood the test
of time it's been around since man first
started settling down together in the
agricultural revolution and where other
industries have come and gone
this one has grown with every single
Industrial Revolution and no matter how
advanced civilization gets this business
will always be here I'm talking of
course about real estate and this is the
path that Graham chose to make his
millions now when I first started
learning about real estate people kept
saying how real estate has made more
millionaires than any other industry but
they never seemed to explain why but
simply where other businesses come and
go on what seems like a daily basis
these days no matter what happens people
will always need a place to live or in
other words real estate will always have
intrinsic value to us we'll always need
shelter and because of that real estate
has a few key benefits that not many
other industries have and I Graham used
to really accelerate his way to
millionaire status the signs were
everywhere but now it's official we are
in a recession if you are watching us
from the last home you'll ever own
tonight consider yourself lucky but if
you're among the millions trying to sell
this was a very bad day the National
Association of Realtors reported the
worst month the month drop in existing
home sales since they started keeping
track in late 90s by 2011 the stock
market had already crashed three years
earlier and was on the way back up but
real estate on the other hand was still
crashing just at a slower rate and was
practically at the very bottom before it
would start to climb back up at that
time you were seeing homes that were
worth 1 million dollars just a few years
back or today sell for only $500,000
that was already a smoking deal to get a
home for half of what it was actually
worth before let area Graham was looking
at it was even better now in San
Bernardino a lot of people lost their
homes this is an area that just boomed
in 2004 or 5 and 6 and got hit
really hard when people started losing
your jobs in the stock market crash and
everything in 2009 then I saw it as just
like a massive overcorrection
I didn't think the market should have
been as high as it was but I didn't
think it should have dropped as low as
it did so when it dropped that low I
thought this is just a major correction
this is just gonna be temporary now is a
good time to buy but at the same time
people were renting because nobody was
buying the people that lost their homes
couldn't afford to buy another house and
a lot of the people that could buy homes
just weren't buying because they were
afraid of the market and I figured you
know what I can buy a property and just
rent it out these are properties by the
way in San Bernardino that were selling
like two hundred and fifty sometimes two
three hundred fifty thousand dollars
that were now selling for 60 70 grand at
the time Graham was living in LA and San
Bernardino was around an hour away and
he knew that these prices were just too
good to pass up so this is what he did I
would make an offer sight unseen cash
for every property that came on the
market that fit my certain criteria and
this was my criteria
[Music]
so at 21 years old after going through
hundreds and hundreds of potential
properties Graham bought his first
rental property for a mere $60,000 in
cash
practically a fourth of what it was
really worth so I go in and I realized
in this house it's owned by a
drug-addicted hoarder I can't even make
this up but they were like needles
everywhere and she must have had like
five years worth of trash just items of
everything just piled up after it was
all said and done he was making around
$1,200 passively every single month just
from the tenant paying rents with just
as property alone it's worth around 250
to 280 thousand dollars today around
three to four times the money he put
into it with just as property alone his
net worth today would be at least
$250,000 or another way to put it is
that he would be at least a quarter of a
millionaire today but as you may have
guessed Graham did not stop there not
too long after moving into 2012 he got
two more properties in the same area
with a similar discount and similar
numbers so in 2011 2012 I bought three
properties it was two houses and a
triplex and with just these three
properties alone Graham was probably
bringing in roughly three to four
thousand dollars in cash every single
month just from the rental income and if
he stopped there he would probably have
reached at least a million dollars in
net worth today making him a million
dollar millennial but he's not just a
million dollar millennial he's a six
million dollar millennial and after
buying property number four in 2016 in
West LA and property number five which
was a duplex two years ago in 2017 and
property number six which was another
duplex a year ago in 2018 lab brings him
to today with an estimated net worth of
six million dollars by the age of 29 and
now in 2019 after paying all the
mortgages and property taxes and
insurance and repairs and everything
else that comes along with that
I am netting every single month about
$4,800 in net profits in my pocket in my
bank
count every single month and when you
look at the timeline of Graham's journey
from this perspective it's actually not
that complicated
he bought six properties starting from
when the housing market was at the very
bottom after the Great Recession and
since purchasing them they've all gone
up in value over the years to where he
owns around four million dollars in real
estate after you account for how much
money he still owes to the banks and
what the money he has in cash and other
investments his net worth is around six
million dollars but it's not the whole
picture we know that real estate has
stood the test of time but why why did
Graham feel so confident in real estate
that he was literally throwing all of
his money into it for eight years
straight and still to this day happiest
investment they have ever made
at last the Bryan's have all the space
they need since people always need a
place to live and that population keeps
growing or in other words that the man
keeps rising real estate typically goes
up in value over time meaning just like
what happened to Graham if you buy a
house today in a decent area a few years
later even one year later it would
typically be worth more money than what
you paid for without you really having
to do anything but appreciation is it
anything special after all the stock
market typically goes up in value over
time as well but Graham still chose this
over stocks why it's because of the next
few reasons that really put real estate
on a whole other playing field compared
to other investments like stocks because
homes are usually a pretty safe bet
because people just live in them and
it's pretty hard for a home not to be
useful because someone can always live
in it and get value out of it this makes
it practically infinitely easier to
borrow money to buy a house more than
something like stocks to put this into
perspective in real estate you can own a
$500,000 house with as little as $25,000
in cash to put down on the loan whereas
in the stock market to control $500,000
in stocks and therefore make money when
the stocks go up in value or not you
typically have to have at least $250,000
or 50% in cash to put down meaning you
have to have 10 times more money in cash
compared to real estate to own the same
amount of money in stocks this makes
real estate so much easier to get
started and and it's so much easier to
make more money at the same time because
of a fancy term called leverage this is
where like an hour scenario if you had
$25,000
you could either own a $500,000 home
because real estate gives you more
leverage or you could own just $50,000
in stocks and in this scenario if after
one year if the home went up just 4% in
value
you made almost all of your money back
or $20,000 with only having to have
$25,000 in cash to start where if you
leverage your money to get $50,000 in
stocks even if the stocks grew twice as
fast at the home at 8% after one year
you only made a measly $4,000 starting
with the same amount of money so you got
5 times more money by just going with
real estate or stocks in this scenario
now typically most people put at least
20% down on a home but even in that
scenario real estate would still make
you more money because real estate
offers more leverage but it doesn't stop
there because even though you still owe
the bank the rest of the money for the
$500,000 home that you gotta loan for it
doesn't come out of your own pocket you
don't even pay the loan to the bank with
your own money because the tenant pays
for it every month when they pay you
rents so not only are you safely
leveraging your money to make more money
someone else is basically paying you to
own a home and any rent money left over
after paying the bank every month that
is oh sweet cash flow just for you
pouring Graham's case with his first
three properties since he bought it all
in cash all the rent money he gets goes
directly to him
[Music]
now you're probably thinking to yourself
like well this is great Jake but I don't
have any money how am I supposed to get
started in real estate in the first
place well that is the last piece of the
puzzle because Graham was in the same
situation for the most part there are
three stages a person like Graham goes
through in life learning how to save
money learning how to make money and
learning how to multiply your money
there is no doubt that real estate
investing is the main thing that got
Graham to become a millionaire because
he was able to multiply his money by
putting money into rental properties and
then the money gets multiplied back in
the form of cashflow appreciation and
tax benefits but by the time the golden
opportunity of real estate came around
in 2011 if Graham hadn't already learned
how to save money and make money leading
up to that opportunity he would not be a
millionaire today because he wouldn't
have had enough money saved up to take
advantage of all these cheap houses it
was so important for me to save as much
money as it could I think if I just blew
all the money I had when as like 18 19
and 20 by the time I was 21 I wouldn't
have had anything left over to take
advantage of these opportunities so
saving money for me it was like a total
priority and even to this day I save as
much money as I can so that when
opportunities do come up you have the
money to take advantage of them
Grahame grew up in a household where his
parents were living paycheck to paycheck
you know when I was 16 years old both of
my parents filed for bankruptcy around
the same time and I remember having 20
bucks and really making that 20 dollars
last so he was already conditioned to
save money and be cheap I mean be a
financial minimalist so he already knew
how to save money the next piece was
learning how to make money and for that
he decided to work as a real estate
agent and the advantage of doing
something like this is a sense it's all
Commission base Graham could control how
much money he made but that also came
with the downside of him spending his
first ten months as an 18 year old
making next to nothing before he even
got his first sale and as he started
getting into the groove of being an
agent by 2011 when the market was at the
very bottom he was making well over a
hundred thousand dollars a year as a 21
year old and had $200,000 in cash saved
up because he's a financial minimalist
at that point even though he was making
great money
it was so unpredictable to where he
could go for months without selling a
home and the reason why I thought that
was because real estate for me even
though I was making decent money at it
was pretty inconsistent and I felt very
uneasy knowing that I'm only as good as
my last deal and so even though you
might make a $50,000 Commission it could
be six months before you make another
one of those and it was that
inconsistency that really made me feel
nervous knowing that I don't know when
my next paycheck is gonna be and I don't
know how much that paycheck is going to
be for and it was this uncertainty and
his income that motivated him to get
into real estate investing in the first
place he started out with an occupation
where he was able to make a ton of money
in a short period of time and control
his income but even with a super high
income is still really hard to get to
millionaire status by age 26 so he
needed what's known as leverage so
instead of spending all that money he
dumped it into a medium that can
multiply that money ie rental properties
repeat this process of selling real
estate as an agent and funneling all
that money into more and more rental
properties and then fast forward eight
years later with over a hundred twenty
million dollars sold in real estate and
sick
rental properties and that brings
crammed to today the six million dollar
millennial
so thank you so much for watching and
being part of me watch to the end Club
you guys I really enjoy making these
videos so if you enjoy the style of
video please consider subscribing by
clicking that big red button down below
for more videos like this every single
week and you can turn on that
notification bell to so YouTube notifies
you whenever I release a new video but
that's gonna wrap it up you can follow
me on instagram at jake trend ah i oh
you've been awesome
I'm in Jake I'll see you guys in the
next one
[Music]